حاله من الغضب عمت في المجتمع النسائي
الليبي خلال الايام الماضيه ذلك كله بعد
قيود جديده فرضت على سفر النساء جهاز
الامن الداخلي الليبي في طرابلس بدا
بتنفيذ قرار الزام النساء الراغبه بالسفر
دون مرافق بتعبئه بيانات تذكر فيها المراه
اسباب السفر بمفردها نشطات حقوقيه اعتبرنا
ان هذا القرار
يؤساء ويقوض حقهن المكفول بالقانون المحلي
والدولي بالسفر يعد هذا القرار صادما في
ليبيا حيث يعرف او يعرف القانون الليبي
بكونه الاكثر تقدما في المنطقه فيما يتعلق
بحقوق المراه بالتاكيد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات